[Musik]
zweieinhalb Wochen nach dem Aufstand der
Wagner sollten ergab Wladimir Podien ein
auf erstaunlicherweise aufschlussreiches
Interview das wohl als ungewollt
entlarvender Moment in die Geschichte
Russlands eingehen dürfte nachdem der
Präsident auf dem russischen Forum
versuchungstechnologien seinen
Kommentaren zum Thema quantentechnologie
von sich gegeben hatte fragte in der
Journalist andere kolesnikow von der
Kremmel tollen Tageszeitung von Sand was
sich während seines Treffens mit den
Anführern der wagnergruppe am 29 Juni im
Kreml zugetragen habe zunächst versteckt
sich Putin in mehr oder weniger
langweiligen Details dass die Sitzung
drei Stunden gedauert hätte 35 Wagner
Mitglieder gekommen wären und er ihre
großen Verdienst auf dem Schlachtfeld
großzügig gegenüber ihren Missetaten
während der Meuterei abgewogen habe doch
dann fragte ihn ja Journalist ob die
wahre Gruppe als Kampfeinheit eigentlich
erhalten bleiben solle und plötzlich
verlor Putin die konnte nass fast schon
erotisch fuhr es aus ihm heraus nein die
Wagner privat Armee gibt es nicht wir
haben kein Gesetz für private mil
Organisationen das gibt es einfach nicht
eine solche juristische Person gibt es
nicht die Gruppe existiert aber
rechtlich existiert sie nicht tja es
passiert nicht oft dass sich der
russische noch Herrschaft von den
eigenen Journalisten in Verlegenheit
bringen lässt und schon gar nicht dass
er sich dabei in verzweifelte
bürokratische Spitzfindigkeiten flüchten
muss sich selbst innerhalb einer Minute
widerspricht und wir später in diesem
Video noch genau sehen werden
anschließend auch noch seine absolute
Machtlosigkeit auf dem Bart der Camel
bröckelt von innen heraus und das sagen
nicht nur wir nein dies ist sogar das
Fazit des Kommissar redakteursnikow am
Schluss seines Interviews auch bei der
Präsident wahrscheinlich anderer Meinung
ist hat der Wagner Aufstand nein die mir
Putin zwei los getroffen wohlgemerkt
diese Zeitung gehört dem Oligarchen alle
Osman auf der als gastron Manager unter
Putin reich und mächtig geworden ist
er gilt als großer Liebling Putins und
wurde von ihm sogar mit der Verwaltung
der gewaltigen Finanzströme der
russischen staatsmafia betraut ja wir
dürfen nicht vergessen das wäre es in
Russland nicht mit einem normalen
Staatswesen und einer normalen Regierung
zu tun haben viel mehr bewegen wir uns
dort durchgängig in einem politischen
und rechtsstaatlichen Nihilismus in der
Welt des organisierten Verbrechens der
beste Beweis dafür war ja das bringt
euch denn für seine Leute Reihe und den
Abschluss von Armee Fliegern keinerlei
Strafe fürchten muss und in der Natur
eines solch inhärentkriminellen Systems
liegt es eben auch dass ihre wahren
Mechanismen und Hintergründe nie ans
Licht der Öffentlichkeit gelangen dürfen
weil sie dann zusammenbrechen würde doch
genau in diesem System brodelt es
momentan so gewaltig wie nie
der Putsch ist gelungen die Befugnisse
innerhalb der herrschten Mafia werden
jetzt so umverteilt wie ist die
Verschwörer geplant haben eine
Umverteilung der Macht hat stattgefunden
und es ist möglich dass einige Personen
aus dem inneren Kreis von Präsident
Putin den Staatschef unter Druck setzen
den Krieg zu beenden damit der abgesetzt
werden kann der versuchte Staatsstreich
der von jewgen angeführten wagnergruppe
hat die Paradigmen des Systems Putin
schon schwer erschüttert zum ersten Mal
ist so richtig klar geworden dass die
eigentlich überragende Macht des
russischen Präsidenten nicht mehr das
ist was sie früher einmal war dass die
Kontrolle die seine Regierung über das
eigene Land ausüben kann eine klare und
vor allem sichtbare Grenzen gestoßen ist
in etwas mehr als einem Jahr ist
Wladimir Putin von einer starken
schafsinnigen und geflüchteten
Führungspersönlichkeit praktisch dem
neuen Zaren Russlands zu einer Art
geworden einem von der Realität
losgelösten Führer eines
auseinanderfallenden Landes der
meisterhafte Jongleur der ist mehr als
20 Jahre lang verstand die verschiedenen
Interessengruppen im Land gegeneinander
aus spielen hat sein Gleichgewicht
bereits verloren einige seiner
Spielbälle sind ihm direkt ins Gesicht
geschlagen er taumelt und hat scheinbar
die Übersicht verloren der Krieg läuft
schlecht die Verluste häufen sich und im
nächsten Schritt des Verfalls Prozesses
Wagen die Warlords erste Versuche den
Kreml mit Gewalt herauszufordern
Wladimir Putin wird bald mit einer neuen
Rebellion konfrontiert sein die niemand
aufhalten wird niemand wird sich einem
neuen Aufstand gegen Putin
entgegenstellen denn es macht keinen
Sinn sein Leben zu riskieren um eine so
miese und miese Rabe Regierung zu
verteidigen
Igors trailkov Gerken ehemaliger FFP
Offizier und nationalistischer Hardliner
vor zwei Jahren wäre uns dieses Szenario
noch völlig abwegig erschienen 1
Szenario in dem ein bedeutender
russischer vorlaut offen gegen den
oberbefehlshabert Armee Hubschrauber und
Flugzeuge abschießt und danach nicht
bestraft wird sondern im Gegenteil seine
Bedingungen erfüllt werden das Kommando
über seines hölder behalten zu dürfen
denn wenn man sich in einen Krieg wie
den in der Ukraine stürzt und ihn dann
nicht gewinnt dann kann man eine Menge
Ärger bekommen man muss viele
Abhängigkeiten eingehen seine Macht mit
Leuten die man unbedingt braucht Teilen
man spielt zwar noch teile und herrsche
aber man ist nicht mehr unbedingt der
alleinige Herrscher die anderen Spielen
es mit einem auch Putin hat seine
Untergebenen gären gegeneinander
ausgespielt um sie als Sündenböcke für
sein eigenes Versagen zu nutzen niemand
verliert gerne aber wenn etwas schief
geht muss es immer einen Schuldigen
geben hat es geschafft dieses Spiel
gegen Putin selbst umzudrehen indem er
sich besser darauf vorbereitet hat als
ein Boss deshalb haben wir euch hier auf
Politik bereits erklärt wie es nach
Russlands misserfolgung strapaz sind
gegen Japan und am Ersten Weltkrieg zur
Revolution von Februar 1917 kamen und
nein wir sprechen nicht von der
bolschewistischen Revolution wir
sprechen von der Revolution die schon
Monate zuvor stattfand sie war keine
kommunistische Revolution sondern eine
progressiv bürgerliche Revolution als
sie ausbrach versuchte der Zahl den
Aufstand mit Gewalt niederzuschlagen
aber die militärgern sagt petersburg
molterten und achteten seine Befehle
eine Woche später dankte Nikolaus II ab
na seht ihr irgendwelche Parallelen nun
es stimmt zwar dass die wagnergruppe
nicht die Armee ist und dass der
russische Präsident im Moment nicht
abdanken musste aber so wie es aussieht
sind die Wagner sollten nicht die
einzigen die mit der Kriegsführung durch
Putins ewigen
unzufrieden sind
russische general sagt dass die obersten
Militärs die in der Ukraine kämpfenden
Soldaten verraten haben generalmaier
Ivan Popo auf der die 58 Jahre
befehligte sagte er sei als Kommandeur
entlassen worden nachdem er die
militärische Führung über die
katastrophalle Lage an der Front in der
Ukraine informiert habe er sagte die
oberste Militärführung seit den
russischen Soldaten durch ihr Versagen
in den Rücken gefallen die ukrainische
Armee konnte unsere reiner davon nicht
durchbrechen aber unser Oberbefehlshaber
hat uns von hinten angegriffen und die
Armee im schwierigsten und intensivsten
Moment bösartig enthauptet dessen
militärisches Rufzeichen Spartacus
lautete und der russische Einheiten in
der Südukraine befriedigte sprach Ex den
Tod russische Soldaten durch ukrainische
Artillerie an und sagte der armee-fehle
es angeeigneten Artillerie Abwehrsysteme
und an der Aufklärung der feindlichen
Artillerie eine solche öffentliche
Kritik eines Kampf erprobten Generals an
der russischen Militärführung die
weniger als drei Wochen nach der Wagner
Meuterei geäußert wurde wurde auf eine
anhaltende Unzufriedenheit innerhalb der
russischen Armee Hinweisen ganz genau so
sieht's aus das Verschwinden des
Generation als mutmaßlichen mit
Verschwörer scheint nur die Spitze des
Eisbergs zu sein es zeigt sich immer
mehr dass der Tiefe graben des
Misstrauens nicht nur zwischen scheuge
und Prägungen verläuft sondern das auch
wichtige Teil der Armeeführung an
Strategie und Kompetenz ist
Verteidigungsministeriums zweifeln denn
wenn die sogar dazu für das deswegen der
Kommandeur des zurzeit wohl wichtigsten
frontabschnittsein SAP gefeuert wird
muss die Kacke schon ordentlich am
dampfen sein sprich die Differenzen sind
unüberbrückbar geworden welche konkreten
Konsequenzen der Fall Papa haben wird
werde ich euch am Ende des Videos genau
erklären an dieser Stelle ist erstmal
wichtig zu wissen dass Putin nun Versuch
wird die Abweichung in den Reihen der
Armee über das camel-treu
Verteidigungsministerium und natürlich
mit Hilfe seines Geheimdienstes FSB kalt
zu stellen allerdings bediente damit
auch nur wieder einen alten stereotyp
und erhöht die Spannungen zwischen
militär-geheimdiensten ob nkwdkgb oder
dem Nachfolger FSB auf der einen Seite
und dem russischen Militär auf der
anderen Seite gibt es nämlich schon
seitdem die Bolschewiki an die Macht
kamen vielleicht sogar schon länger
traditionell wechselten sich im Kreml
jeweils die Favoriten der
Geheimdienstler und der Generalität ab
während die Machtübergabe meistens nicht
besonders einfach nämlich und friedlich
verlief putin war ein paar Gebet
Offizier und auch Martin FSB Präsident
und identifiziert sich daher eng mit der
spionageorganisation und General suchen
wir gehen hingegen haben glühende
Anhänger in den russischen Militär
Kreisen und bei den russischen
Nationalisten weil man glaubte dass sie
bereit waren das Armee Esstisch und vor
allem Verhalten Strukturen im
Verteidigungsministerium aufzurütteln
eine absolute Notwendigkeit um noch den
Krieg gewinnen zu können Putin wurde
also nicht nur von Verteidigungsminister
dazu gedrängt den immer beliebter werden
im prägossen zu entmachten sondern auch
von seinen fsd-pumpen dies führte
natürlich zu ernsthaften
Auseinandersetzungen zwischen dem
Militär und dem FB die bis jetzt
andauern und ihrem Ende noch lange nicht
in Sicht ist ganz im Gegenteil das
klassische und die gesagt traditionelle
Tauziehen zwischen diesen beiden
Institutionen um die Macht den Russland
geht wohl erst so richtig los
in den kommenden Monaten ist mit neuen
Kampagnen zu rechnen die nicht nur
darauf abzielen das
Verteidigungsministerium der Russischen
Föderation zu entkernen sondern auch den
Einfluss von patrochef und den Teilen
des FSB die sich der Kontrolle der
dahinter stehenden oligarischen Gruppen
entziehen zu zerschlagen vorerst werden
sie alles tun um sicherzustellen dass
sie dringend notwendigen Maßnahmen zur
Vorbereitung der Armee Heimat von und
Industrie auf einen langen harten Krieg
nicht ergriffen oder so weit wie möglich
verzögert werden bis hin zu großen
Niederlagen an der Front verursacht
durch fehlender Reserven und Mangel an
Personal militärischer Ausrüstung und
Munition wohin dies letztendlich führen
wird es noch unklar wir müssen uns aber
für gegenwärtigen das ist sich bei
beiden Gruppen buchstäblich um Mafia
Clans handelt die Milliarden von Dollar
verwalten und unter sich aufteilen
gewaltige Brocken der russischen
Volkswirtschaft viele führende
Angehörige der Streitkräfte halten es
fast für einen hohen das
Verteidigungsminister Scholl oder keine
militärische Erfahrung hat in einem
katastrophal verlaufenden Krieg das
Sagen hat unter ihnen kursiert gar nicht
Verschwörungstheorie beim Ukraine
Feldzug würde es sich um ein
ausgeklügeltes komplettes FSB handeln um
das Militär zu zerstören gut wir können
jetzt nicht sagen was da dran sein
könnte ausschlaggebend für die
Kampfmoral an der Front sowie die
Loyalität gegenüber putin ist aber eher
wie das alles von der Generalität über
das offizierskorb bis zu den Fußsoldaten
wahrgenommen wird wenn der Eindruck
entsteht das Putin das Militär nicht
ausreichend unterstützt oder es gab zu
Gunsten des FSB und den mittlerweile 37
privaten Militär und benachteiligt
könnte dies eine drastische Reaktion
auslösen gegen die Putin nicht viel wird
ausrichten können das zeigte sich ja
bereits bei Prinzen Durchmarsch nach
Roßdorf und dann auf Moskau der
Widerstand seitens der Armee war minimal
alle warteten erstmal ab wie sich die
Dinge entwickeln würden um sich bei
Bedarf mit Pregarten zu verbinden und
den fsbern Putin zu stürzen für viele in
der Armee wäre das eine große genug
gewesen umgekehrt nutzen Putins FSB
Amigos nur natürlich die derzeitige
Situation um ihn davon zu überzeugen
dass man den Militär nicht trauen kann
es sieht also immer mehr danach aus als
würden diese beiden Fraktionen der
russischen macht beginnen sich aktiv zu
bekämpfen ein ausgewachsener Mafia Krieg
zwischen Militär und FFB dieses
umfangreiche Thema ist jedoch sicherlich
ein eigenes Video Wert aktiviert also
bitte falls nicht bereits geschehen
jetzt das ab und unbedingt auch das
Glöckchen um es ja nicht zu verpassen
außerdem ist mehr als klar dass die
Ähnlichkeiten zwischen der heutigen
Situation und 1917 immer deutlicher
werden und vergesst bitte nicht das
nicht nur wir das sagen sondern auch
Putin selbst in seiner Botschaft an den
Nationen die er während des Söldner
auftanz von Evgeni kuscheln hielt hört
es euch
Anna rot
ary 201
für euch verlinkt aber wieso hat Putin
selbst ausgerechnet die parallel zur
Revolution von 1917 bemüht die für das
damalige Regina katastrophal ausgegangen
ist nun die entscheidende nicht mehr
rückgängig zu machen eine Tatsache ist
dass ein erster bewaffneter Aufstand
gegen das als unerschütterlich geltendes
System Putin bereits stattgefunden hat
bisher ist es zwar nicht gelungen Putin
selbst komplett zu stürzen aber allein
der Fakt dass er sein Strafbefehl gegen
die Mutter zurückziehen musste spricht
beende er konnte sich noch nicht mal
damit die geilsten Wagner aufzulösen und
die Mitglieder in die Armee
einzugliedern wie wir am Ende dieses
Videos sehen werden ist er zu einem
regelrechten Bittsteller geworden und
auch wir wissen nicht wie diese ganze
Saga enden wird aber die Ereignisse
werfen sicherlich einige interessante
Fragen auf wie könnte eine Russland nach
Putin Aussehen wer könnte ihn im Amt
ersetzen was sind die politischen Folgen
des Wagners könnte er Putin wirklich
langfristig geschwächt haben auch wenn
alles so schnell wieder vorbei war und
alles umsonst gewesen zu sein scheint
oder wird Putin am Ende gar gestärkt aus
dem ganzen Schlamassel hervorgehen meine
Lieben Zuschauer in diesem Video werden
wir all diese Fragen auf der Grundlage
konkreter Fakten beantworten und wisst
ihr was die Revolution von 1917 ist
nicht die einzige historische Parallele
die wir zu aktuellen Situation finden
können es gibt doch eine andere viel
aktuellere Entwicklung die uns sehr an
das erinnert was wir nach Russland
Scheitern in der Ukraine bereits jetzt
erleben und noch erleben werden am Ende
dieses Videos werdet ihr genau verstehen
welche bedeutende historische
Entwicklung sich gerade jetzt abzeichnet
allerdings ist auch dieses Video wieder
aufgrund der Komplexität des Themas
etwas länger geworden als gedacht
weswegen wir uns entschlossen haben
einen Zweiteiler daraus zu machen auf
diese Weise bekommt ihr den ersten Teil
schon etwas früher zu sehen und morgen
bekommt ihr dann mit dem zweiten Teil
den abschließenden Überblick vergesst
also bitte nicht das Abo mit Glöckchen
um ideal nicht zu verpassen sofort würde
ich euch jedoch gerne darum bitten sich
die folgende kurze Botschaft unserer
Sponsors anzusehen der das heutige Video
mit seinem Beitrag erst möglich gemacht
hat als aufmerksam Politik Zuschauer
habt ihr vielleicht schon bemerkt dass
ich in den letzten Monaten etwas
abgenommen habe vielleicht sieht man es
mir ja nicht gleich an aber wichtiger
ist sowieso dass ich mich jetzt einfach
viel bitter fühle im vergangenen Jahr
war meine Arbeitsbelastung aufgrund des
Krieges enorm angewachsen und ich hatte
Schwierigkeiten den Stress auf gesunde
Weise zu kompensieren die Folge
Bewegungsmangel schlechte Ernährung und
Fettpölsterchen ich musste etwas
unternehmen als erstes habe ich meine
morgen umgestellt vor dem Protein
reichen und zuckerarmen Frühstück kommt
jetzt immer eine Runde Krafttraining um
das Muskelwachstum anzuregen davor muss
ich jedoch erstmal meinen
Energiestoffwechsel in Schwung bringen
und hierbei unterstützen mich folgende
Bestandteile meiner allmorgendlichen
Portion AG one Kupfer
biotinsäure tiamin und die Vitamine B2
B12 und C das ist nicht einfach so daher
gesagt sondern eine evidenzbasierte
Tatsache klar ist natürlich diese
Routine ersetzt keine ausgewogene
Ernährung aber sie hilft mir dabei viel
gesunde und unbelastete in den Tag zu
starten ich fühle mich gesättigt aber es
gibt nicht mehr dieses typische low nach
dem Frühstück wie früher denn man
Insulinspiegel bleibt schön konstant und
das Ergebnis kann sich wahrlich sehen
lassen innerhalb von fünf Monaten bin
ich von 104 auf 93 Kilo runter aber was
viel wichtiger ist ich bin nicht nur
sechs Kilogramm Körperfett los geworden
an ihre Stelle sind auch noch gut zwei
Kilogramm Muskelmasse getreten natürlich
ist LG nicht nur für diesen meinen
individuellen Anwendungsbereich geeignet
bietet noch viele weitere
gesundheitliche Vorteile über die ihr
mehr erfahren könnt wenn ihr auf den
Link in der Beschreibung klickt dort
erfahrt ihr auch weitere Details über
gesundheitliche Einschränkungen und auch
darüber welche Inhaltsstoffe genau
welchen Nutzen bringen und wie sie
optimal aufeinander abgestimmt sind um
Synergieeffekte und eine hohe
Bioverfügbarkeit zu erzielen fakt ist
ht-one ist kito-freundlich und die 75
wertvollen Mikronährstoffe wurden aus
echten natürlichen veganen
Nahrungsmitteln wie Erbsen oder Soja
gewonnen ohne künstliche Zusatzstoffe
außerdem schmeckt es auch noch gut mir
zumindest
natürlich darf man lg19 die alles im
Leben nicht überdosieren sollte auf
Allergene achten und vor allem nicht
einnehmen wenn man schwanger ist oder
stillt ich kann euch auf jeden Fall
empfehlen mal eine Ernährungsberatung zu
machen um festzustellen was genau ihr
braucht um euch besser zu fühlen und
gesünder zu leben mir persönlich hilft
die oben genannte Kombination mit LG one
am besten schreibt mir doch in die
Kommentare wie eure Morgenroutine
aussieht und wenn sie nicht so ideal ist
wie ihr sie auf Vordermann bringen
möchtet passend dazu biete von unserer
Community sogar exklusives Angebot wenn
du auf den Link in der Videobeschreibung
klickst erhältst du bei Abschluss eines
monatlichen Abos einen kostenlosen
Jahresvorrat an Vitamin D3 und K5 und 5
praktischer travel Packs für unterwegs
gratis neukunden erhalten außerdem das
AG und welcome Cat inklusive schicker
Aufbewahrungsdose und einen praktischen
Shaker zur Monats Packung dazu
wohlgemerkt das ganze ist ein Abo ohne
laufzeit-bindung jederzeit nach Belieben
anpassbar und kündbar und mit einer sehr
praktischen 90 Tage Geld zurück Garantie
stellst du also nach drei Monaten fest
dass es nicht zu Podcast bekommst du das
Geld für die erste Bestellung einfach
wieder zurück ohne dass du dafür
irgendwelche Gründe angeben musst also
worauf wartest du noch probiere Angie
wollen doch einfach mal ganz
unverbindlich aus und unterstützt auch
deine Ernährung auf einfache und gesunde
Weise und falls ihr eventuell Lust
hättet unsere arbeitsunterstützen damit
wir euch noch viele schöne informative
Videos liefern können den Spenden Link
dazu findet ihr ebenfalls in der
Videobeschreibung wir danken schon mal
im voraus so und nun lasst uns auf eine
spannende Reise aufbrechen in eine
Russland nach Putin auf geht's
der Fall des roten Reiches
wenn uns die Geschichte Russlands etwas
lehrt dann das Regierungswechsel und der
Kampf um politischen Einfluss in diesem
Land normalerweise keine ruhigen
Ereignisse sind Verschwörungen
Vergiftungen Säuberungen extrem
zufällige Todesfälle Staatsstreiche und
Verrat an jeder Ecke die
Geschichtsbücher sind voll dieser
russischen Spezialitäten von der
Vertreibung bis zur Entlassung aus
schoss durchbrechen oder der Tortur die
Gott schafft durchleben musste und die
schließlich das Ende Union selbst
verursachte lasst uns doch mal einen
Blick auf den letzten Fall werfen um
nicht zu tief in der geschichtskiste
wühlen zu müssen schließlich bringen die
Menschen die ihn selbst miterlebt haben
noch immer das Leben und Geschehen im
Land es handelt sich um ein eigenes das
vielen großen also gar nicht so fern
scheint im Jahr 1991 befand sich die
Sowjetunion in einer Krise das
kommunistische Imperium schien zunehmend
erschöpft der damalige sowjetische Staat
hat Michael Gorbatschow hatte einen
Reformprozess eingeleitet er die per
Post die wirtschaftliche
Umstrukturierung und die Glasnost eine
Politik der Öffnung beinhaltete
diese Veränderungen stellten eine
Revolution dar sie beendeten viele der
Grundlagen des alten sowjetischen
Modells was natürlich nicht jedem gefiel
wir haben über den Zusammenbruch der
UdSSR übrigens ein sehr interessantes
Video gedreht dass ich euch verlinken
werde für das Verständnis dieses Videos
ist erstmal nur wichtig dass viele
Mitglieder der Kommunistischen Partei
der Armee und der Geheimdienste die
Veränderungen Gorbatschows als Verrat an
den sowjetischen prinzipiensahnen und da
die Bevölkerung unter einer schweren
Wirtschaftskrise mit schienen die Russen
von Gorbatschow auch nicht besonders
begeistert zu sein
[Musik]
im Grunde genommen geriet das
Reformmodell ins Trudeln und im August
1991 unternahm eine Gruppe hochrangige
apparatschix die als staatliches
notstandskomitee bekannt war einen
Putsch um die Macht im Staat an sich zu
reißen Gorbatschows Reformen rückgängig
zu machen und zum alten sowjetischen
Modell zurückzukehren und obwohl der
Putsch erhebliche Unterstützung
innerhalb des Staatsapparats genoss
scheiterte er ist endlich der damalige
russische Vizepräsident barcel 10
spielte eine Schlüsselrolle bei den Push
zu verhindern er fuhr buchstäblich in
einem Panzer vor und rief zum zivilen
Widerstand gegen die Putschisten auf die
Moskauer reagierten darauf oder putscht
scheiterte innerhalb von 3 Tagen
trotzdem war Gorbatschows macht stark
beschädigt so sehr dass in den folgenden
Monaten die verschiedenen Republiken aus
den die USA bestanden begann sich von
Moskau zu entfernen und schließlich
wurde die Sowjetunion am 26 dezember des
selben jahreskampf 4 Monate nach dem
gescheiterten Staatstreich aufgelöst das
rote reichbahn nun Geschichte ja der
Putsch vom 19 August 91 ist gescheitert
aber gleichzeitig hat er zum
vollständigen Zusammenbruch der Union
der Sozialistischen Sowjetrepubliken
geführt der springende Punkt ist nun das
Russland 2023 in einer sehr schwierigen
Zeit wird das Land nicht nur den ersten
bewaffneten Aufstand gegen Putin erleben
musste sondern auch das ist nach seinem
scheinbaren scheitern weiterhin kräftig
brodelt daher stellt sich die
berechtigte Frage ist für Putin wirklich
schon alles überstanden in die weit ist
der Fortbestand seines Regimes weiterhin
gefährdet den wir vor einem ähnlichen
Szenario wie man gescheiterten von 1991
oder gar nicht 1917 nun das werden wir
jetzt genau unter die Lupe nehmen
aufgepasst
[Musik]
der hoch hinaus will
der erste Angriff gegen die mit Putin
hat bereits stattgefunden angeführt
wurde er von dem Mann den ihr auf dem
Bildschirm sieht und den ihr sicher alle
schon kennt jetzt gehen die brikosch in
dem Gründe und Anführer der Wagner soll
in der Gruppe
der Mann war bis zum Ukraine Krieg in
der breiten Weltöffentlichkeit kaum
bekannt Gregorian ist ein alter
Verbündeter Putins der sich in den
letzten Jahren im Aufbau eines riesigen
Netzwerks von Tentakeln in Putins
Diensten verschrieben hat
als der russische Präsident zum Beispiel
seine Invasion in der Ukraine startete
wollte er sich erstellen dass der Krieg
keine Nationalhelden hervorbringt wie es
mit ihm selbst als russischer
Gallionsfigur aufnehmen könnten und
deswegen wurde general Alexander als im
Sommer 2020 relativ beliebt zu werden
automatisch abgesetzt aber das ging
natürlich nicht einfach so die
Propaganda musste entsprechende Gründe
generiert und um ihn in den sozialen
Medien zu diskretieren wandte sich Putin
an die Firma Patriot diese betreibt zum
Beispiel trollfarmen und eine
Medienfirma für die Verbreitung von Fake
News für die Führung medialer Kriege
als die russische Armee in der Ukraine
völlig am Boden lag und keinen Sieg mehr
erregen konnte sich in erneut an seinen
travelshooter damit diese eben mit
seiner privaten Söldner Firma Wagner
ganz tolle da und dann auch Bach Mutter
erobert und pregorian hat in allen
Fällen geliefert Wagner war ein Jahr
lang das einzige erfolgreiche Element
der russischen Invasion und ihr Erfolg
war sehr begrenzt und konzentrierte sich
auf eine kleine Stadt und ihre Taktiken
waren selbst für Wagner Standards aber
wenigstens haben sie etwas erreicht das
konnte die russische Armee nicht die
Tatsache ist und das ist vielleicht das
Überraschendste an dieser ganzen
Geschichte das Putin zwar sicherstellen
wollte dass der Krieg in der Ukraine
keine potenziellen Konkurrenten
hervorbringt aber am Ende hat er es dem
Anführer der Wagen eine Gruppe selbst
leicht gemacht sehr beliebt zu werden so
beliebt das ist Anfang 2023 bereits
Journalisten gab die ihn als Kandidaten
für die Nachfolge Putins Ansagen man
könnte sagen das bringt euch in alle
Stufen übersprungen und die große
Mehrheit der russischen Silo Wiki und
ich gar nicht überholt hat er hatte eine
Menge Geld verdient auch wenn er nicht
der reichste von ihnen war er hatte viel
Macht erlang er hatte eine privat
ziemlich beliebt sowohl innerhalb Armee
als auch in der russischen Gesellschaft
[Musik]
sein prometenhafter Aufstieg begann im
Sommer 2022 als er durch russische
Gefängnisse tourte um Gefangene für
seine Privatarmee zu rekrutieren er bot
allen gefangen die in der Freundin der
Ukraine gekämpft hatten Begnadigungen an
sechs Monate die ist im Austausch für
die Freiheit und wie wir im vorherigen
Video über die Situation in Russland
nach den beiden berichtet haben hat ihn
auch nicht gezögert Videos aufzunehmen
und zu veröffentlichen in denen er die
unnötig hohen Verluste an russischen
Soldaten kritisiert er hat ihren Witwen
und Müttern öffentlichkeitswirksam
Geschenke gemacht und vor allem
Wahrheiten über den Krieg gesagt die
sich in Russland sonst niemand zu sagen
traute
auch seine scharfe Kritik an
Verteidigungsminister Sergej scheuge und
generalstoffe ihm geholfen dass Image
eines effektiven und unabhängigen
Kriegers zu erlangen eines echten
patriotischen Führers denn erster Linie
ein sein Volk denkt und an die Soldaten
nicht an sein eigenes Konto und
Luxusyachten erschuf mit sich ein
Vorbild für das starke und große
Russland von den immer spricht das aber
durch seine Missmanagement unglückliches
Händchen für seine Personal und fatale
Fehlentscheidung ins Banken zu geraten
scheint und auf diese Weise ist im Laufe
des Jahres 2023 immer mehr dazu
übergegangen die Interessen der
russischen Soldaten zu vertreten und zu
verteidigen es ist gut möglich dass ein
bewaffneter aufstand und die Tatsache
dass er unantastbar scheint und
niemanden kennen ist wagt ihn zu
verfolgen viel mit seiner immensen
Popularität zu tun haben der russische
Journalisten Michael Sieger schrieb
bereits im Januar 2023 folgendes ist 26
Januar 2023 in naher Zukunft könnte
Harry Goschen den Präsidenten
herausfordern und Herr bisschen könnte
nicht mehr in der Lage sein sich seinem
ehemaligen Chefkoch zu widersetzen vom
Chefkoch zum Chef eine ziemliche
Vorahnung findet ihr nicht auch und bei
Ingolstadt trat dann auch noch in einem
seiner Videos bewusst präsidial auf so
als wolle er seinen Fans und den folgt
demonstrieren Putins Theatralik kann ich
auch aber ansonsten mag ich eher
bodenständig soll heißen ich habe nicht
vergessen dass ich einer von euch bin
aber ihr solltet auch wissen dass ich
mindestens genauso viel auf dem Kasten
habe wie der aktuelle nun Jahre ältere
Krempel Boss
fakt ist niemand anderen hat Putin so
sehr populär werden lassen alle anderen
die es wagten an seine Beliebtheit im
Volk auch nur entfernt heranzukommen
wurden abgesägt und unschädlich gemacht
Gregorian bildet die absolute Ausnahme
eine so große Ausnahme dass in Putin
auch noch nach der Revolte stehen zu
bestrafen im Kreml empfing zusammen mit
den Warner Kommandeuren eine nie da
gewesener Vorgang und dabei ist es
vollkommen egal ob Putin von Prägungen
einfach viel zu abhängig ist oder die
beiden in Wahrheit verschwunden sind und
alles nur ein Theater war was sehr
unwahrscheinlich ist angesichts der
PR-Kampagne die der Krempel gegen
Gregorian gestartet hat inklusive
Vorwürfen unter demütigen
Veröffentlichung der Videos oder
Durchsuchung seines Luxus anwesend in St
Petersburg Putin signalisierte damit
dass er durchaus noch weißen kann vor
allem mit Hilfe des FSD der
anschließende präsidiane Empfang der
Partner der Delegation war dann die
typische respektbezeigung unter Alpha
Menschen die nach der gegenseitigen
macht Demonstrationen und beide wissen
dass keiner von ihnen über genügend
Macht verfügt und den jeweils anderen
auszus halten zumindest nicht ohne sich
dabei selbst akut arg zu gefährden denn
durch eine sofortige Liquidierung
brigorgens zu der diese immer genügend
legitime Gründe geliefert hat könnte
sich Putin bei weiten Teilen sowohl der
Bevölkerung als auch des Militärs der
Erd unbeliebt machen dass die Säulen
seines Systems noch stärker wackeln
würden als den Pre Goschen erstmal ein
freier Mann ist und ihm vielleicht noch
mal nützlich sein kann wie stark und
entscheiden zurückhalten bei seiner
Truppe ist offenbar schließlich Putin
selbst im Eingang anbieten Interview mit
dem kommissant die Wagner Kämpfer hätten
sich alle an einem Ort versammeln und
weiter dienen können und für sie hätte
sich nichts geändert sie würden von
demselben Mann angeführt werden der
schon immer ihr wahrer Befehlshaber war
viele nickten als ich das sagte und
brigoch in der folgende saß und es nicht
gesehen hat sagte nachdem er zugehört
hatte nein die Jungs sind mit dieser
Entscheidung nicht einfach verstanden ja
damit dürfte wohl klar sein wer hier das
wirkliche sagen hat wer hier den
wirklich braucht
gut gesagt er habe versucht trinke euch
nach der Wagner Meuterei zu entmachten
sei aber gescheitert Vladimir Putin
sagte er hätte versucht jetzt gehen die
Pre Goschen als Anführer der
wagnerkämpfer in der Ukraine abzulösen
und das er damit gescheitert sei nachdem
der Söldner Chef sein Vorschlag bei
einem Treffen im Kreml abgelehnt habe
während des Treffens habe er Prickeln
die Option angeboten die Wagner Kämpfer
unter der Führung ihres Kommandeurs
André treu Chef weiter in der Ukraine
dienen zu lassen aber es gab auf ein
politischer Berater und ehemaliger reden
Schreiber Putin sagte die Tatsache dass
ich die beiden getroffen hätten zeige
das Putin bereits seit die Beziehung zu
Gregorian zu normalisieren wenn Putin
und pregorien ihre Emotionen beiseite
schieben würden beide Akteure national
betrachtet lieber Frieden schließen
damit Russland die Wagner Truppen in der
Ukraine einsetzen kann beide Seiten
brauchen sich gegenseitig verboten ist
das höhere Ziel der Krieg in der Ukraine
während weiß dass seine Position ohne
den Präsidenten sehr wackelig ist auch
die naive Vorstellung viele
Außenstehender Putin hätte die
uneingeschränkte Macht einfach jeden
Morgen zu lassen der ihm nicht in den
Kram passt es totaler Quatsch die
makaberen Witze über offene Fenster oder
vergifteten Tee sind nämlich nur für
einen bestimmten Personenkreis kritisch
Leute die pregorian können über sie nur
lachen i'm not in danger i am the danger
Putin hat eine Reihe von Journalisten
Oppositionellen Anwälten Manager und
exspionen ermorden lassen diese hatten
aber keinerlei Unterstützung innerhalb
der Oligarchie es handelte sich um
extrem leichte Ziele im Gegensatz zu
diesen armen Seelen die Putins von
schutzlos ausgeliefert waren es bringt
euch ins Position jedoch nicht nur bei
Volk und Soldaten sondern auch innerhalb
der neuen
klaturfügt werden wahrscheinlich nicht
bereit sein gegen derart harte
Konkurrenz vorzugehen weil sie die Rache
dieser Gruppen mehr fürchten als Putin
Strafe wenn sie sich weigern seine
Befehle auszuführen na erinnert euch das
nicht irgendwie an
1917 wir dürfen vor allem nämlich nicht
vergessen das pregorian bei weitem nicht
der einzige und vielleicht auch nicht
der Spitzenkandidat für die Nachfolge
Putins ist vielleicht sieht Putin in
bregorian im Vergleich mit den anderen
potentiellen und subatoren sogar eine
viel geringere Gefahr für sich na seid
ihr gespannt welche Namen jetzt kommen
dann dürft ihr schon auf den zweiten
Teil dieses Videos gespannt sein den wir
euch schon morgen präsentieren werden
dort werden wir euch nicht nur die
heißesten Kandidaten auf die russische
Thronfolge verraten sondern auch alle
heute vorgestellten Zusammenhänge zu
einem logischen Gesamtbild
zusammenführen falls ihr euch genauso
interessieren wie uns dann klickt jetzt
unbedingt was ich schon geschehen auf
den Abo Knopf und das Glöckchen um das
morgige Video nicht zu verpassen ich
verspreche euch es lohnt sich und bis
dahin könnt ihr uns ja in den
Kommentaren schon mal verraten wenn ihr
als potenziell Nachfolger Putin seht
oder glaubt ihr etwa das Putin noch ein
Durchbruch gelingen wird wie jetzt in
1993 oder ähnelt die Situation in
Russland heute eher das wird Union von
1991 oder gar den zahlreich von 1917 wie
immer sind wir von der Diskussion zu
diesem Thema schon mächtig gespannt und
wie immer dürfte auch diesen Teil schon
mal ein Like geben falls er euch
gefallen hat teilt ihr bitte auch mit
euren Freunden und diskutiert mit ihm
darüber vergiss bitte auch nicht dass
ihr unsere Arbeit mit einer Spende
unterstützen könnte den Link dazu findet
ihr in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
mach's gut und bis morgen